special agent john hardly fbi  been tracking your scores for a while  now  every city  every heist  [Applause]  now that you've been tagged  with red notices  you become the world's most wanted  criminals  and i'm the only one who can bring you  in  where'd you get that jacket it's a  statement piece somewhere there's a very  nude cow whispering  [Applause]  [Music]  looking for something specific or just  browsing you're under arrest oh my god  read the room  i just want the eggs  help me catch her and i will help you  teamwork  and direct you know  team team  team which feels weird  [Music]  how's it going with your partner in  crime we're work-wise we're not  work-wise  we're not any kind of wives  [Applause]  we both know that this whole thing is  gonna end  with unhandcuffs  promises  promises  by buyer john john hartley  [Music]  you